مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
معركه بين ريال مدريد وبرشلونه والمشاكل
اللي صايره والقصه اللي وصلت لحد قطع
العلاقات التامه على ما يبدو بين الناديين
الموضوع من البدايه ولحتى نفهم من الاول
يتعلق بقضيه نيجريره شو هي قضيه هي القضيه
اللي اتهم فيها برشلونه بتقديم اموال
لنائب رئيس لجنه الحكام السابق خوسيه
ماريان
وتم التهاب برشلونه في عهد بارتوميو
وروسيل بانه قدم اموال لهذا الرجل او
لشركه تابعه لهذا الرجل او لابنه ايضا
واستفاد ربما من التحكيم بشكل او باخر
برشلونه طبعا ما نفع انه قدم اموال لابناء
رئيس لجنه الحكام ولكن نفى بشكل تام انه
هاي الاموال تكون اثرت باي شكل من الاشكال
على نتائج مبارياته وعرض حالات تحكيميه
على مدار تلك الفتره اوضحت ان برشلونه ما
كان عم يتم عم يمتاز او عم بيحصل على
امتيازات تحكيميه بسبب الاموال اللي دفعها
نظر برشلونه كانت نحن قدمنا اموال لهذا
الرجل او لهذه الشركه لحتى نحصل على
تقارير تتعلق بالتحكيم تتعلق بالاستشارات
المتعلقه بالامور التحكيميه والقانونيه
وبالتالي امورنا النظاميه مثلنا مثل اي
نادي اخر لهون ريال مدريد برا اللعبه ما
له خصم بالموضوع نهائيا القصه بين المدعي
العام الاسباني وبين برشلونه والانديه
الاسبانيه بلشت شوي شوية تدخل باللعبه
وتتحرك لحتى تعترض على موضوع تقديم
برشلونه اموال
وبينما كانت الانديه الاسبانيه عم تتحرك
للانضمام لهاي المعركه بجانب مكتب المدعي
العام ضد برشلونه كان ريال مدريد عم يجتمع
مع مجلس ادارته
ومجلس اداره ليقرروا انه كمان يصبحوا طرف
بهاي اللعبه ضد برشلونه ومع مكتب المدعي
العام
ومع بقيه انديه الدوري الاسباني هون بلشت
المشكله والصدام المباشر ما بين ريال
مدريد وبرشلونه
رفض انه يحضر الكلاسيكو الاخير اللي كانت
بسبب هذا الموضوع
او التوترات الموجوده على بسبب هذا الامر
وكانت رساله انه في حاله من التوتر وشبه
انقطاع للعلاقات بين النادي الامور ما
وقفت هون لانه
يصعد القصه اكثر واكثر
ويهاجم حليفه بشكل مباشر وبنقول انه
فلورنتينوبريز هو حليفه لانه هم الاثنين
كانوا متفقين موضوع السوبر ليج ضد الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبالتالي طلع بمؤتمر صحفي لبورتا
هاجم ريال مدريد بشكل مباشر وبشكل واضح
وصريح وبالاسم وسماه فريق النظام فريق
النظام وهنا يشير لبورتا لانه ريال مدريد
يعني استفاد من السلطه في اسبانيا كونه
فريق تابع للحكومه الاسبانيه وخصوصا بفتره
فرانكو وما تبع ذلك من سنوات طويله
بالنسبه لريال مدريد طبعا ريال مدريد يقعد
ساكت اكيد لا طلع ورد على وكان الرد بانه
نشر فيديو لتصريحات لبورتا على صفحته
الرسميه على تويتر شملت ايضا
لقطات لوجود فرانكو بملعب الافتتاح ولعدد
الالقاب اللي حققها برشلونه باحد فرانكو
وربما حمايه فرانكو لبرشلونه من الافلاس
وعدد الالقاب ريال مدريد بنفس الفتره
ليقولوا انه فريق النظام هو برشلونه مش
ريال مدريد
الامور هون وصلت لمرحله تقريبا شبه قطيعه
مثل ما حكينا في ناس صارت تحلل هاي
التفاصيل وصارت حلل هاي الاحداث بتقول لك
والله ربما هي في نظريه مؤامره بالموضوع
يعني ما بين برشلونه وريال مدريد ما بين
فلوريد ولا بورتا ضد الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
نعمل فيلم انه نحن متهاوشين ضد بعض ولكن
على ارض الواقع نحن بنكون عم نلعب لعبه
لحتى بالنهايه نمشي موضوع السوبرليك اكيد
هو فلورز ذكي ولا بورتا ذكي ولكن الامور
اللي عم تشوفها اليوم تصل الى حد مثل ما
حكينا القطيعه بين برشلونه وريال مدريد
وهي سابقه من نوعها في تاريخ الناديه لانه
دائما كان في تنافس في مشاكل ولكن ما شفنا
قطيعه بالشكل اللي عم تشوفوا حاليا لذلك
موضوع نظريه المؤامره انا مش قادر افهمه
بصراحه ولا قادر استوعب يعني شو الهدف من
وراء اذا كان هو حقيقه لانه على ارض
الواقع هذول الرجلين او الطرفين او
القطبين في اسبانيا ما في اي داعي لانهم
يعملوا اي نظريات مؤامره ضد الاتحاد
الاوروبي لحتى يمشوا اللي بدهم اياه لا هن
كانوا عم يواجهوا الاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل
مباشر عم يطرحوا افكارا بشكل مباشر وعم
تدافعوا عنا بكل شجاعه ولذلك لا اعتقد ان
الموضوع يتعلق باي شكل من الاشكال
بقضيه السوبر ليج ولكن الموضوع بالدرجه
الاولى والاخيره هو صراع بين قطبين في قطب
استفاد من خطا قطب اخر وعم يحاول يحقق
اكبر المكاسب الممكنه منه كمان بمبدا
تساوي الفرص في ناس بتشوفها هيك كذلك ممكن
وفي طرف اخر عم يدافع عن نفسه وشايف حاله
متهم بجريمه لم يرتكبها ان كان من جانب
ريال مدريد او ان كان من جانب الانديه
الاسبانيه او ان كان من جانب الاتحاد
الاوروبي اللي عم يحقق بالتهم الموجهه
لبرشلونه والمفروض يصدر حكمه فيها بعد شهر
او شهرين تقريبا
لوين بدها تمشي تطورات الاحداث بين ريال
مدريد وبرشلونه هذا امر متروك للوقت ولكن
الان العلاقه بين الناديين تمر باسوء
فتراتها على الاطلاق هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه
لون بعض الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل